what does justice really mean do those
in law enforcement have a responsibility
to behave more ethically than the
average citizen
these are the big questions at the
forefront of the latest psychological
thriller
making waves on hbo max the little
things
the film stars a trio of academy award
winners as deputy sheriff joe deacon
played by denzel washington gets wrapped
up in a los angeles crime investigation
with detective jimmy baxter played by
rami malik taking the lead
there's a serial killer on the loose and
both men obsess over figuring out who's
behind these deadly attacks
their search brings them to an outcast
by the name of albert sparma
played by jared leto who seems to fit
the profile but when it comes to solving
a case as messy as this one
not everything is as it seems the little
things is one of the first movies
subject to the bold new release strategy
from warner brothers
that sees films debuting simultaneously
in theaters and on
hbo max the radical distribution plan is
designed to sidestep
issues created by the ongoing covert 19
pandemic
as such there's a lot riding on the
film's success even though we may not
have any official numbers on how well
the film has done on the streaming
platform as of this video
it seems to have caught on with
audiences don't worry we won't spoil the
ending for you here
no don't say anything no spoilers the
response from professional critics has
been decidedly mixed on the little
things
according to rotten tomatoes so far it's
garnered a 48
critical score which is a bit shy of
fresh but it's doing a lot better when
you look at what general audiences have
to say
by audience metrics it has a rating of
64
with over 250 reviews accumulated the
general consensus among audience members
is that the three leads washington
malek and leto are phenomenal in this
film and really give it their all
one of the verified audience reviews
praised zuzleto's work in this
the acting was fantastic i never thought
jared leto could be this creepy
it had some really suspenseful moments
leto
stated that he drew inspiration for this
role from a surprising world leader
north korean dictator kim jong-un the
results are suitably creepy and
entertaining
as any good psychological thriller
should the little things has a way of
burrowing into your mind
and making you rethink everything you've
seen in the film one reviewer by the
name of farlissa writes
this is a mind twisted movie my husband
and i are still replaying the event in
our heads
with other comments like quotes movie is
a must-see
and unexpected ending but still exciting
and worth the watch
it's clear this film while perhaps
divisive is likely worth a watch if
you're a fan of thrillers
in the event you're still on the fence
about whether or not to give the little
things a chance
then perhaps it's prudent to compare it
to a different thriller held in high
regard
7. the 1995 neo noir starring morgan
freeman
brad pitt and gwyneth paltrow is one of
director david fincher's best films
both due to the moody atmosphere it
creates as well as a shocking ending
that still terrifies audiences to this
day
a lot of people over on twitter are
comparing the classic 90s film
with the little things with game over
luke writing if you like
7 then watch the little things such a
good movie regardless of people's
opinions on the film overall
one thing is clear people love denzel
washington in this and pretty much any
other movie he's in
after all it's not a coincidence that
you see comments like denzel is the best
actor of my time
and denzel washington is still the
greatest of all time among the fan
reviews
as with any movie it's best to watch it
for yourself to form your own opinion
you can check it out on hbo max until
the end of february
if one thing is clear from all this is
that you don't want to be left out of
the conversation
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite new movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one